sin fundamento santiago porque hasta
ahora no ha podido entregar pruebas
contundentes el propio secretario de
estado del estado de georgia le dijo en
esta llamada que se filtró que el
problema era que el presidente trump
simplemente no tenía pruebas no tenía
pruebas para justificar este fraude que
sigue apelando que siguen apelando los
miles de simpatizantes que vinieron acá
washington a pedir que donald trump
silla en la casa blanca dona un pico que
está increíble que job alguien haya
sacado más de 80 millones de votos y
repite varias veces y esto es importante
resaltar lo que no va a dejar que ocurra
este robo sin embargo en este momento no
hay forma constitucional de que donald
trump siga en la casa blanca y pues para
este proceso de confirmación por parte
de joe biden el presidente trump también
resaltó la labor de rudy giuliani su
abogado que se ha metido en varios líos
legales y que de hecho una audiencia ha
dicho que efectivamente carece de
pruebas de este supuesto fraude que
alega el presidente trump lo dijo en
audio
en principal jazz sin embargo ante los
medios y en estas marchas públicamente
siguen alegando que hubo fraude lo que
dicen muchos analistas santiago es que
el presidente trump quiere salir de la
casa blanca con el mensaje de que a él
le robaron las elecciones y que no las
perdió no vamos a dejar que esto suceda
dijo también cristóbal pero qué margen
tiene para maniobrar de ahora en más
sí pues dice el presidente trompa además
que pues la gente que fue a
para apoyarlo en la casa blanca pues es
mucho más de la esperada y que
precisamente los medios de comunicación
son los que se han robado esta elección
por insistir y pues por publicar los
datos los datos que ofrecen los los
estados los organismos estatales y los
organismos electorales de cada estado y
pues insiste entonces entre los medios
de comunicación son los grandes
responsables de su derrota horas antes
de que don orione saliera aquí al
escenario a dar este discurso pues
fueron sus hijos los que estuvieron
diciendo que no reconocen los resultados
también el vicepresidente maitén según
un artículo del new york times' está
diciendo este artículo de new york
times' que se encuentra el
vicepresidente con gran presión con gran
presión por parte de donald trump para
que en unos en unas horas aquí en el
congreso no reciba los votos de los
delegados electorales que rechace los
votos de los delegados electorales que
ya están certificados en cada estado y
que entonces además de los 12 senadores
y de los 140 representantes a la cámara
van a objetar estos votos electorales se
sube el vicepresidente sin embargo en
una reunión que filtra new york times'
el vicepresidente le habría dicho según
otro que él simplemente no tiene el
poder de rechazar los resultados
electorales